ナマステ飲ませてこんにちははじめしゃ
ちょーです皆さんはベイブレードという
ものをご存知でしょうか男の子だったら
知ってる人多いかもしれないねベイブレー
ドって何かって言うと
昔からのぞみのベーゴマとか米遊びある
じゃないですかあれの現代版のおもちゃと
して進化したのがベイブレートっていうの
があるんですけれどもベイブレードって
いうおもちゃもね結構歴史がもう長くて俺
が小学生の時にやってたもうシンプルな
ベイブレードもうめちゃくちゃみんなやっ
てたし購入するのが難しいくらい大人気
でしたでベイブレードの次の世代のメタル
ファイトメタルファイトっていう金属で
できたこうベイゴマにより近くなった
メタルファイトってやつがあってでさらに
次の世代のベイブレードバーストこれ結構
最近の世代で僕も遊んでましたバチバチに
バーストって言ってね
ぶつかり合って威力強すぎたらボーンて
バーストして壊れちゃうっていうイベント
バーストもかなり遊びましたしもう
ありがたいことに僕コラボではじめしゃ
ちょーベイブレードも作って頂いたりして
も本当に
ですがそのベイブレードバーストもついに
終わり新世代次世代のベイブレードが発売
されるらしいですおめでとうございます
この名もベイブレード
バースト
その名もベイブレード
Xなるものが出るらしいんですよ
これ以上どう進化するとだってもう初代
めっちゃ面白かったさらにそっからなんか
メタル感出してメタルファイトバチバチの
もっと面白くなったさらにそこから
ベイブレードバーストぶつかったら破壊し
てしまうよもっと面白くなったフレーム
レート完成形までいってんじゃないかって
なんかいつからだもうすぐ発売なんですよ
もうすぐレベルデックスいつから発売いつ
かというとあ2023年の7月の15日
もうすぐですねもうすぐ発売なんですが
今家になります
ごめんなさいごめんなさいってか別に悪い
ことしないんですけどもその
ベーグルドレックスが発売されるっていう
情報を聞いてええと思ってめっちゃ軽い
気持ちでマスターブレイダー堀川さんって
いうそのベイブレードの公式の方が
いらっしゃってベイブレード開発者なん
ですよその方とちょっと面識あってその人
のTwitterになんかやりたいと思っ
たら
見てくれましたマスターブレード
ありがとうというわけで発売前に
ベイブレードX家にあります
やった持ってきますはい持ってきました
いいんかな発売前に遊んじゃって
ある
入ってますこれが多分ベイブレード
なんかスタジアムすごいなスタジアムの
周りが君より広いので囲まれたすいません
俺全然まだベイベックスの情報わからなく
てもう無知で今ここに立ってるわけです
いやもうすぐ発売で手に入るんですけども
ちょっとだけ早くちょっと朝させてもらい
ます
嬉しいガチでベーグルト好きなんですよ俺
なんかガチで好きすぎても普通になんか
ベビーのこと結構ね1日の2%ぐらい
考えるんですよ割と少ないかわりと少ない
けどどんなことしてても絶対俺の脳内に
ベイベレター2%くらいあるっていうそれ
ぐらい結構ね昔から好きなおもちゃでは
あるんですが今回ねテーマがすごいんです
よちょっとホームページ見てみましょうか
ベイブレードXほらもうなんかちょっとね
スト
リートっぽいんですよね今回のテーマが
スクロールしていくとベイブレードは
スポーツで聞いたかみんな
スポーツなのよもうスケートボードが
オリンピック種目になったゲームが巨大な
スポーツ産業になったスポーツの定義は
変わっていくけれどそこにはいつも本能を
刺激する普遍があるベイブレードXそれは
スポーツへ向かうベイブレード鼓動を
生み出すほどギアは鋭く
駆け引きはシュートの瞬間まで続く体中の
血が勝利へ蠢く20年を超える進化の先に
ここからどこまでいけるか一番
遠くて面白い未来を始めようもう
遊びじゃない
[音楽]
今回のテーマはもう
遊びじゃないってことらしいです
ベイブレードスポーツになるんかなやっぱ
時代ってさすごい変わってきてさゲームは
遊ぶものだったじゃないですか昔はそれが
最近はさプロゲーマーだったりEスポーツ
ゲームをスポーツなんですよまさに今書い
てありましたけどもスケートボードも
オリンピックの種目になりもうスポーツも
定義は時代によって変わっていく変えて
あることそのまま言ってます確かにな
ベイブレードはその
競技性もあるしスポーツになり得るんじゃ
ないかという気はしたわ今の見てそんな
ベイブレードX早速開けてみたいと思い
ます
案件じゃないからもう思ったことズバズバ
言うわすまんな堀川さん案件じゃないから
もう俺はもう言うよユーザーとして
ちょっと今回遊ばせてもらいます最高え
すごい4つも入ってましたレッドグリーン
ブルーイエローと4つ入ってますえー
かっこいいちょっと1個ずつ見ていき
ましょうかまず赤いのこれは絶対攻撃型
ヘルズサイズっていう名前ですね
スターターだからもうシューターと
ベイブレードが一緒に入ってますねを
アプリと連動するっぽいすごいな
狙いだな裏にねそのアニメとかも一緒にや
るっぽくてこのベベルと使ってる
キャラクターとタイプとか書いてあるお
バランスバランスタイプなんだバランス
取れてる系か赤いなこれバランスタイプね
じゃあ多分
緑色になるディフェンスタイプもうこれお
決まりです
本当だやっぱりかっこいいねでもデザイン
ナイトシールド緑はねやっぱねディフェ
スっぽいイメージがあるんですよ次は
イエローイエローはねえっとね自給自給
自給ほいやっぱり実況タイプ長く回転
できるんでしょうねとなればもう主人公は
青でしょう
毎回なんかねベイブレードの主人公という
かアタックタイプは青っていうイメージが
ある俺の中ではね
[音楽]
わからん
主人公2人いる青いのがドランソードって
名前だねもう名前は主人公はいはい
アタックタイプねそうだよね
攻撃タイプごめん俺アニメの情報全く
分かんないけど両方主人公っぽいんだよな
ダブル主人公かちょっとわかんないです
けどもなるほど最初の4種類はこれね
アタックタイプ
ディフェンス時給バランス3つのパーツで
構成されてるっぽいですね1枚目が
ブレードかこのぶつかる部分ね
ブレードラチェットなんか間に入るやつか
ビットってやつがそのベイブレードの下の
回転する地面にくっつく部分え今までの
ベビー何が違うんだ絶対
スタジアムに何かある絶対スタジオに何か
ありますだって今までこんな君より広いの
なかったもん開けてみていいですか
失礼します
[音楽]
すごいなんか
ギザギザしてるなちょっと組み立てます
[音楽]
スタジアム完成ですなんか変わった形して
ないすっごい不思議な形をしてますねこれ
が標準のスタジアムなのかちょっとまだ謎
が多いですけども続いてベビルト出して
いきたいと思いますすぐ
遊べるえ
っかっこいいなんかめっちゃでファイトっ
ぽいというか真ん中のデザインもすごい
かっこいいなえ今回イケメンか
なんかここ
でこれを多分当てるんだろう
[音楽]
な全然わかんないこことここを絶対重ねる
んだよな
入ったでブレードを抑えながら一回勝ちっ
て言ったこれでいいのかなあこれでロック
されましたねで最後
これで完成か結構パッと取れる感じなのに
よしできましたこれがドランソードなんか
めっちゃメタル感あってかっこいいなよし
そこでも全部作ってきます
もう作り方わかったぞ
すごいすぐできる
はいというわけで4種類全部完成しました
かっこいいんだよこれなんか結構メタルっ
ぽいなシンプルなデザインだけど金属が
やっぱ強いですね個人的にこのグリーンの
発色がめっちゃ綺麗ですねディフェンス
タイプっぽいグレードしてるなぁで裏の
このビットもね全然多分全部違うのよもう
上からだと分かりづらいんですけど見ても
全然違う
攻撃タイプとか見てもめっちゃ平べったい
から多分これねめっちゃ早いの基本って
動くバランスタイプはバランス良くて感じ
だけど時給タイプとかもすごいのよ
丸くなってる先端がこれずっと多分ね
スピードとかはないけど回り続けるタイプ
です
ディフェンスはもうすごいね尖ってるね
もうスピードもクソもないんだろうな
ずっとその場でこうやって
止まり続けるタイプな気がします全然個性
が違うなぁあとね思ったのがね重い結構
重量感あるのでこれ
めっちゃかっこいいわうわなんか今
ようやく開けて手に持って新しいベイ
ブレードが始まるのかっていう実感がわき
ましたじゃ早速回してみたいと思います
よし行くぞみんな
ベイブレードの新時代の始まりだ
もう遊びじゃない321
そのアウトラインに沿う
今見ましたちょっと待って一瞬の出来事
すぎてちょっと
捉えられてたかわかんないですけど
[音楽]
これねアタックタイプの宿命なんですよ
すぐ止まる
かっこいい見ましたこれあれか
ギザギザしてるって言ったじゃないですか
さっきこのスタジアムのコーナーの黄緑色
の部分がこれこいつらの先端もギザギザし
てるからこのギザギザが噛み合って
ぎゅーんってスピード上がるんですよギュ
ンってこれが新機能なのかちょっともう1
回やってみますね321
うわーすごいすごい
ぞめっちゃ加速するぞこれなら打ち勝ち
次第ではもっといいすぐ
[音楽]
激しいそうやって使うのねこの周りの緑は
バランスタイプとかどうなんだろう赤いの
使ってみますアタックタイプだけも特権な
のかな321
おーすごい
激しいスタミナタイプでやってみます
スタミナとは
最初あまりまくって後からこの冷静さ俺
ねー好きのタイプというかスタミナタイプ
好きなんですよ
めっちゃ回転が静か
[音楽]
いや美しいにも程があるぞこれ
あーやばいテンション分かってきちゃっ
てる自分がいるいやさすがにディフェンス
タイプには無理ですよあんな激しいこの
コーナリングの動き僕にはできませんって
言うてます行くぜ
321ゴーシュ
[音楽]
さすがにディフェンスタイプはそうか
シュートの場所にもよると思うんですけど
ももうディフェンス栽培もほんとこういう
やつ真ん中陣取って相手の攻撃をいなして
守り続けるこれもまたねベイブレードの
戦い方の一つですちょっと待って
おもろいいや皆さんおもろいです
めっちゃかっこいいこれメタリックなのが
すごくいいですねこれテンション上がるわ
えー
めっちゃいいじゃないですか
戦ってみるかこれちょっと一人遊んでても
面白さあんまり伝わらないと思うので
ちょっと対戦してみますわさあ対戦相手と
呼びましたどうぞよろしくお願いしますお
願いします
対戦相手のボルテックエイプさんです
よろしくお願いします
発売前のベイブレードXだベイブレードX
なんかもう特殊すぎるギザギザ何そして
ボルテープにはこれを
かっこいいじゃんなんか俺はこれ
色的に勝てそうだな
久しぶりだベイブレード
よろしくお願いしますお願いします行くぞ
待って強すぎる
何も見せれんかった新しいギミックがある
のよこれなんか前のやつも壊れる感じだっ
たもんね
バースト機能は残しつつも見せたかった
なぁ
[音楽]
本当に
行きます32155
[音楽]
俺はじゃあこれで行きますわトランス
ソードです
スリープはご主人
行きます
あーいやいやいやいやどこ
走れるの
まずい
これ一番強いです
熟力がないんだろうなあーなるほどね
[音楽]